after the bombshell revelations in
Prince Harry's book the question remains
what's motivating the former Army
helicopter pilot to speak out with such
devastating Candor if you're in a
self-destructive Behavior Philip Ingram
met Prince Harry at his commissioning
ball at Sandhurst and says his Sparkle
has gone
he recognizes what he says is
self-destructive behavior in the prince
which he believes could be a cry for
help a lot of the behaviors I'm seeing
Prince Harry are almost triggers for me
they remind me of some of my behaviors
whenever I suffered quite severe PTSD
and in your mind this is not someone
who's behaving vengefully or feeling
bitter it's someone that needs help
definitely we shouldn't be attacking him
we should be putting a big protective
bubble around him because he's falling
apart and that bubble should allow him
to fall apart in as protected away as
possible and then catch the pieces and
put them together again and before he
does himself any real harm
whatever the impact of the card's life
has dealt Prince Harry his is no
ordinary family to be gunning for
the Royal was functioned through a
curtain of Mystique the Mystique has
been torn back and Harry is saying this
is what it's like there's briefing
against each other there's jealousy
between the households you see a lovely
family picture and smiles and the
balcony waves and these marvelous
romantic Weddings But even Harry said
they even the wedding he said was a show
of unity he said he wasn't really best
man even though we all thought he was to
William
learning what some believe is a bit too
much about what goes on behind the
closed doors of Britain's royal family
is dividing public opinion I think it's
over sharing a bit to be honest of
course I feel sorry for him for what he
experienced as a child but I think he is
monitoring monetizing too much uh his
tragedy I feel like since he is part of
the royal family they do have to monitor
some of the things they say but I also
think it's wonderful that he's getting
to share the things that he wants to
share
so what's in the book is now known but
there's more to come with the first of
Prince Harry's television interviews due
to air later this weekend
there's still no comment from his family
leaving the public to read between the
lines about what the Royals must make of
it all Lisa Holland Sky News